in terms of like within the faith uh
Christianity um I'm a Christian myself
I'm kind of confused when it comes to
you know disciplines and just seeking
some form of foundation when it comes to
day-to-day um prayer you know just being
grounded how does one get that
>> uh you're asking me a general question
what do you mean like grounded
you got to be more specific grounded
obviously you got to be intentional to
study the Bible and then act upon it
whatever the Bible tells you to do you
have do. That's why you have 66 books if
you're Protestant. You have 73 if you're
Catholic and 27 New Testament. That's
another whole can of worms. But you got
a collection of books that God wants you
to understand and act and apply. So the
first thing that the Bible tells you is
you're part of a church, right?
>> Yes.
>> And when you were baptized in the
spirit, you're united to Christ, right?
>> Correct.
And then that Lord who then united you
to himself united you to other believers
called the church. That's 1 Corinthians
12. So now you have a family. That's
your body that you have to do life with.
So if you read the Bible, what's
important is you got to be now a vibrant
functioning member of the church. So
that's the first thing. Are you a
vibrant functioning member of the
church?
>> Yes.
Okay. So, you are actively involved in
the church.
>> Yes, sir.
>> Okay. So, then that's that church right
there. If it's a Christthonoring church,
we'll then go about administering,
I don't know what you would call it
because I don't know your background,
but the sacraments such as the
Eucharist, obviously been baptized, but
also if it's a healthy church, a vibrant
church, it's going to go through the
scriptures and it's going to break down
the scriptures and it's going to explain
what these scriptures mean and how to
apply it in your life. What we call
expository preaching. And then secondly,
it will also teach you the core
doctrines of your faith, what you're
supposed to believe and why you're
supposed to believe them and how to act
upon them. So, is that what your church
is doing?
>> I would say so. I mean, I'm from New
York City, Brooklyn to be exact. And
it's um it's a killer, man. You a
killer, baby.
>> I would say so. Um when it comes to like
um just the church itself, it's a mega
church. So it's not much of a
>> indiv individualistic in terms of like
being in touch with the preacher and
having
>> you know direct contact with somebody
that's I would say that's closest to
God. So it's kind of a I would say a
struggle in a sense when you're trying
to reach out to people within you know
the same mind frame within the pastor.
>> Yeah. Problem is you're in a mega
church. Mega church there's no
accountability. Usually megaurches will
then tell you to get involved in small
groups where then you can meet people
where you're going to get to know
intimately and personally. So mega
church bad news. Why? Because you're
going to be lost in a sea of people. No
one knows each other and they only see
each other once a week. That's not
church.
>> Okay.
>> Right. In this mega church, how many
people you have?
>> 4,000 I would say. Yeah. How in the
world do you think the pastor is going
to be able to know each member of the
church intimately, personally to them,
speak truth in their life, and shepherd
them? Because a pastor is a shepherd.
How do you shepherd 4,000 people that
you don't know? Because you need to meet
them where they're at and meet their
needs. Well, how I'm going to meet your
needs if I don't know who you are,
>> and how are you going to be family if no
one knows you? You don't know them.
>> Right?
>> Correct. So that's not the church of
Christ, meaning the church in the New
Testament. Now what the megaurches then
do is they make up for that by having
small groups. There are small groups and
they say get involved. So this mega
church, does it have small groups?
>> It does.
>> Okay. So then that's where you're going
to find a family. They're going to know
you personally and you're going to know
them personally and you're going to do
life together and hold each other
accountable. So, are you actively
involved in any of these small groups?
>> I wouldn't say actively. No, I'm not.
You know, I'm
>> That's where you're lacking. See, that's
the thing.
>> Okay.
>> So, if you're going to stay in that
church, then you're going to have to be
actively
persistently
doing all you can to join a small group
where now there's a small number of
people. You're going to get to know each
other inside and out and you're going to
be a body that's going to lean on one
another. So, if there's a brother in
need, he knows he can reach out to you.
for the sake of Christ, you'll be there
and vice versa. And then you're going to
do life together, activities together.
Because church is not just going to
church on Sunday. It's doing life with
your family. And my family is those who
love Jesus and want to honor Jesus and
live a way that will glorify Christ, not
sin against them. Because they say birds
of a feather flock together, right?
>> Yes, sir.
>> So, think about it. If I like martial
arts and you like pool, you know, like
shooting pool, I can't stand shooting
pool. You and I ain't going to click.
>> Notice who click. Those who are
like-minded, right?
>> 100%.
>> So, point being, if I am someone who
loves martial arts, I'm going to
gravitate to martial artists and I'm
going to do life with them, train with
them because there are strength and
numbers. If you like pool, you're going
to gravitate to people who play pool and
then you're going to do life with them.
This is what the church is. finding
like-minded people who have the same
interest and pursuit that you do. They
love Jesus more than life and want to
honor Jesus and live for him. That's the
kind of group you need to be connected
to and inseparable from because the
Bible warns us in 1 Corinthians 15:33. 1
Corinthians 15:33 says, "Be not
deceived. Bad company corrupts good
morals."
>> Wow. So if you hang out with people who
want to party, get high, get drunk, and
have sex before marriage, and you keep
hanging out with them, you're going to
weaken. And in order to stay within that
click
and get their approval, you're going to
start compromising and you're going to
start succumbing and you're going to
start getting high and getting drunk
just so you can feel that you're part of
the band. and to get along. That's why
Paul says in 1 Corinthians 15:33, I'm
giving you the verse again so you can
remember it. Be not deceived. Bad
company corrupts good morals.
>> 2 Corinthians 6:14, we're also told in 2
Corinthians 6:14,
"Do not be unequally yolked with
unbelievers." You don't come under the
same yoke with an unbeliever because an
unbeliever his pursuits and interests
are contrary to what Christ wants of
you. So an unbeliever says, "Hey man,
let's go to nightclub, pick up some
babes." No, I can't have sex before
marriage. What? What you what? Get out
of here, man.
And then either you're going to cave
into that pressure and you're going to
have sex before marriage and then you're
going to suffer discipline or the guy
won't want to have anything to do with
you.
>> Gotcha.
That's why the Lord says, "You are now
part of a body, a body that's
like-minded, that love me more than
anything, and want to do life
in a way that will honor me." And that's
who you need to be with because you're
going to have the same pursuits. Instead
of going to nightclub Saturday night, I
want to go home and pray or sing or read
my Bible, I want to go out and
evangelize. See, that's what someone
who's really sold out for the Lord
>> is going to want to do. And so, if you
want to be sold out for the Lord, you
need to be with people like that.
>> Yes, sir.
>> But you're doing life alone. I can tell.
You go to church once a week. It's a
mega church. You get lost in that crowd.
You may know a few people here and there
high and by. And then six days a week,
you're doing life by yourself, right?
>> Yes, sir.
>> That's why you're weakening. Mhm.
>> Wow.
>> So if you want to stay in that church,
okay, until God then shows you and
brings you the fullness of the truth, go
find that small group. Go get connected.
Go and be deliberate and trying to
belong to a small group of people where
they're going to know you by name.
You're going to know them by name.
They're going to get your number. You're
going to get their number. And you're
going to be doing life together during
the week, not once a week. Yes,
>> sir. Amen. Amen.
>> That's how that's the first step. So you
got to do that. Then it's going to fall
in place. this all will fall in place.
Right? Don't forget the verses I gave
you. 1 Corinthians 15:33, "Be not
deceived. Bad company corrupts good
morals." Also 2 Corinthians 6 14-18, do
not be unequally yolked with
unbelievers. For what fellowship does a
believer have with an unbeliever? And
then it goes on to say, "What communion
is there between Christ and Bile?" Bel
Satan.
>> Does Christ sit in that fellowship with
Satan? Not at all.
>> Then when you sit and have fellowship
with unbelievers and do life with them,
it's like Christ doing life with Satan.
>> Wow.
>> That's what it says.
And then read when you can tonight 1
Corinthians chapter 12. In 1 Corinthians
chapter 12, it's the entire chapter of
what it means to be the church. And it
says the church is individual
believers. a person who's now baptized
into the spirit and by that spirit
baptized into Christ and connected with
other believers and it says that you are
the body of Christ and like a body needs
all its members to function
>> you may be a toe I may be a finger or
you may be an eyeball and I may be an
ear and Paul says
>> every member of that body depends on the
other members to be fully functional and
if one member hurts the whole body
hurts. And that's true. If you have a
toothache, doesn't that throw your
entire b body,
>> right?
>> Yeah.
>> And that's what Paul says the church is.
You have to be so inseparable as a
spiritual body that if one member hurts,
all of you are affected by it. But
you're doing life alone. So when a
church hurts, it doesn't do anything to
you because you're not connected.
>> Wow.
>> Right.
And then it says when one body when one
member is glorified the whole body is
glorified.
Meaning
if anything happens to a member of my
body it's going to affect the rest. Good
or bad right?
>> Yes sir.
>> So that's the whole point. You need to
be so connected to believers that when
you sneeze everyone else gets sick.
>> Wow.
>> Or when you're healthy everyone else is
full of life and vibrant. That's how
it's supposed to be. That's what Paul
says.
Wow.
>> And you don't have that. That's why
you're wondering, "How do I grow?" First
step is get personally involved with
believers. A church is not a building.
It's not a building. It's a group of
individuals loved and adored by Jesus,
made inseparable
from one another and united to Christ as
the head.
>> You need to do that. I know it's hard. I
mean, look at me. I'm in a sea of
loneliness. Meaning, not trying to get a
pity party. I want to be a vibrant
member of a local body of believers, but
it's hard because the people I'm with,
they don't see church that way and they
don't do life the way the Bible says
Christians are supposed to do life as a
family, as a body. In fact, here's your
homeworks assignment for the week.
>> Okay?
>> I want you to go and start reading the
book of Acts. Just the entire book of
Acts. It's 28 chapters. Slowly,
prayerfully. I want you to count how
many times
believers traveled alone rarely and in
desperate situations. If let's say there
was persecution causing them to flee,
then you may find a believer on his own
because persecution came and they had to
flee. But when you read the book of
Acts, you will not find as the normal
way of doing things, Christians going
out by themselves,
one person alone. They went out in
groups, two, three, four, five. They
didn't do it alone.
>> And when Jesus sent out the disciples in
the gospels, he never sent them sent
them out alone.
>> Wow.
>> Right. Because there are strength in
numbers. When you weaken, I can then
strengthen you. And if I weaken, falter,
you can then strengthen me. You got my
back. It's like the gang mentality,
isn't it?
>> It is.
>> Look, listen. We We were not always
Christians. We messed up. Why did you
want to belong to a gang? Because you
wanted to belong, right?
>> I see.
>> You get it, right? Like he's like, "Man,
I don't want to give away." Hey, it's
all right. You're forgiven.
I got it, man. I've been there.
>> Far from that. Far from that. But I got
you, though. I follow. I follow.
>> You get it, right? You went We went
became part of gang because we wanted to
fit in. We wanted to have a, you know, a
company of homies. You know what I'm
saying?
>> I got you.
>> And we and we had each other's back till
death. But now notice, gangs are zealous
for a stupid cause that only brings
imprisonment, drug addiction, or death
with no everlasting benefits. Imagine we
had that zeal to be part of Jesus's gang
called the church.
Wow.
Right?
So that's what you need to do. Go get
involved with like-minded believers. I
gave you the references. 1 Corinthians
15:33. So you can go back and rewind
this.
>> Yes, sir.
>> 2 Corinthians 6 14-18,
the entire book of Acts, and the entire
chapter of 1 Corinthians 12. So you're
not really doing church. You're doing
you, the Bible, and Jesus. And Jesus
says, "Yeah, I love you and I love you
intimately and I love you individually,
but I love you enough to know what's
best for you and it's not best for you
to do it alone because you're not going
to make it."
>> Yes, sir.
>> So, I hope that helped you, brother.
>> It did, sir. Thank you. Really
>> bless you, brother. Come back if you
have more questions.
>> We'll do. Thank you again. Be blessed
and all watching um definitely come to
Christ.
>> Hallelujah. Surrender and submit and
your life will be changed.
>> Amen. Thank you again, sir. Take care.